[Music]
the film business loves to put people in
boxes
you got to play someone who just had a
car crash because you're in a wheelchair
here it's like you don't have that the
dream is to change the way disability of
seen in America there's so much talent
and you speed here with this group on
Iowa healthy and I'm one of the
directors of vino Mountain Farm and I'm
Peter Albee another director as you know
our mission is to support lifelong
friendship an opportunity for people
with and without disability it's
important for us to have integration we
run camps all year long and right now
we're at our film camp we've make movies
for about 12 years now we've done all
different types of genres from the
sports drama movie we just time-traveled
movie we did a super heros movie Western
and this year we're doing a high school
musical the last film we did we went to
film festivals all over in the hope is
that we get to do that with this every
aspect of the film we have the table
talent from the casting to the lighting
to the script writing photo Dale James
and Ruth baby Bedell no Joseph
I'm producer and that's taken a seat
I'm a good alright down for it I'm an
actor I love being in movies debacle we
have two really exciting leads for this
movie Ricky and Roxy go for Roxy hi my
name is Ricky Wilson jr. I'm playing
Tony Michaels hi my name is Roxanne
sabaha and I'm playing sage you guys
ready to roll music the film is
basically about two teenagers
listen who go to summer camp and they
fall in love
sort of a so Maj to a lot of the
classics such as degrees but lose all
the disability just fades away here and
everyone's just a person in outside film
world disability has to be written in a
story people have to know why my
character stage it's never discussed why
she's in a wheelchair and I think that's
so awesome and incredible everyone's
just beaming constantly this is their
lives they live for Xena and you can
feel it we're here
in the disability world there's the
isolation there's this lack of
opportunity that exists you know
everyone understands each other wants to
connect and find the talent and everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]